a last-minute recommendation by the
state public charter school authority is
now
changing how some students are going to
attend school as early as this coming
monday
8 news now reporter kate houston shows
us how this is going to impact families
discovery charter was set to welcome
back some students in person on monday
it's now moving to a fully distanced
model for the next two weeks at both of
its locations this is really only giving
parents a few days to figure out how to
make it work for their families
this comes after nevada state public
charter school authority executive
director rebecca feiden
made a recommendation earlier this week
saying charter schools set to open
before august 24
should do so virtually for the first two
weeks fiden wants schools to have an
opportunity to review the new targeted
covid 19 approach set by governor
sisilak a few days ago
these first two weeks they get a sense
of all this information
have a clear picture we may as we get
more information provide further
guidance but at this point it is just a
two week recommendation
19 charter schools with the spcsa are
set to open on monday
august 10th six of them are now
switching from a hybrid model
to distance learning those are discovery
charter school akipo academy
founders academy quest charter academy
and signature preparatory
i don't take that decision process
lightly for
for all of our schools for all of our
communities this has been a really
challenging time
and i feel it's important that my role i
continue to provide our schools with
information
guidance to best support and serve their
communities and families
an additional 19 charter schools are set
to open the week of the 17th
fiden could not confirm just yet which
of those schools are switching to
distance education
she says the situation is fluid kate
houston 8 news now
this recommendation also suggests a
potential exemption
and it would provide in-person
instruction to students who would be
impacted by not being in school such as
english language learners or those with
special needs